Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Lucia: 你在找什么
Lucia: What are you looking for?
Jake: 没有在晃悠
Jake: Just wandering around.
Jake: 开工吧
Jake: Let's get to work.
Jake: 上班了上班了
Jake: Time to work, time to work.
Jake: 拆快递 2楼可能得收拾收拾
Jake: Unbox the deliveries. Maybe we need to tidy up the second floor.
Jake: 你们今天做狗吗
Jake: Are you guys making dogs today?
Jake: 今天看狗吗
Jake: Are you looking at dogs today?
Lucia: 平时可以做
Lucia: Usually we can do it.
Lucia: 到底是做狗还是看狗啊
Lucia: Are we making or looking at dogs?
Jake: 都可以做
Jake: We can do both.
Jake: 可以看看狗
Jake: We can look at dogs.
Jake: 要不我们建立一些逻辑吧
Jake: How about we establish some logic first?
Jake: 作为一个
Jake: As a...
Jake: 这个也是什么f人还是什么人
Jake: This is also some kind of person or what...
Jake: 建立一些年纪
Jake: Establish some age...
Jake: 我们先看狗
Jake: Let's look at the dogs first.
Jake: 然后按照狗去做狗
Jake: Then make dogs based on the dogs.
Lucia: 建立逻辑是替人
Lucia: Establishing logic is for people.
Jake: 替人好
Jake: For people, right.
Katrina:  那就是先小说看一点狗的款式
Katrina: So we'll first look at some dog styles.
Nicous: 什么是做狗
Nicous: What does "making dogs" mean?
Katrina:  然后开始选择
Katrina: Then start choosing.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  然后再做
Katrina: Then make them.
Nicous: 做狗
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:  做狗它们会有一个一条纸板
Jake: When making dogs, they will have a cardboard.
Lucia:  就是只要只要能只要能画个大概就行
Lucia: As long as we can draw a rough outline, it's fine.
Jake: 然后把纸板变成狗
Jake: Then turn the cardboard into a dog.
Lucia: 头暂时还不需要过多考虑
Lucia: We don't need to worry too much about the head for now.
Lucia: 哦   点
Lucia: Oh, point.
Tasha: 三阶段就能卡着利息升8级我靠
Tasha: You can level up to 8 in three stages by managing interest, wow.
Jake: 要做狗
Jake: We need to make dogs.
Shure: 告密者
Shure: Snitch.
Lucia: 在我的眼镜突然被转歪的时候
Lucia: When my glasses suddenly got turned sideways...
Shure:  丝尼奇懂不
Shure: You know Sneetch, right?
Lucia: AI会不会以为地震了
Lucia: Will the AI think it's an earthquake?
Jake: 那可能地震频率过高
Jake: Then maybe the earthquake frequency is too high.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 也没有很经常吧
Lucia: Not very often, right?
Jake: 好好
Jake: Okay okay.
Lucia: 我只是刚才突然转到线了而已
Lucia: I just suddenly switched to the line earlier.
Jake: 那没电了
Jake: Then there's no power.
Jake: 确实和地震
Jake: Indeed, with the earthquake.
Lucia: 我需要一根笔老板
Lucia: Boss, I need a pen.
Jake: 什么笔
Jake: What kind of pen?
Lucia: 随便什么笔
Lucia: Any pen will do.
Lucia: 能在纸箱上面画出来线就行
Lucia: As long as it can draw a line on the cardboard.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 还有我们之前买的彩笔是还没到吗
Jake: And the colored pens we bought earlier, have they arrived yet?
Lucia: 好我们已经实现无纸化工作了
Lucia: Well, we've already gone paperless.
Lucia: 现在没有笔是吧
Lucia: So we don't have any pens now, right?
Jake: 是没到是吧
Jake: They haven't arrived yet, right?
Shure: 我们要不要臆想出来一只纸狗
Shure: Should we just imagine a paper dog?
Lucia: 因为我害怕一直用这白板笔
Lucia: Because I'm afraid of using this whiteboard pen too much.
Lucia: 给他用没墨了
Lucia: It'll run out of ink.
Jake: 嗯买买买
Jake: Hmm, buy, buy, buy.
Jake: 所以没到还是还是怎么回事
Jake: So it hasn't arrived yet, or what's going on?
Jake: 之前买的这个
Jake: The one we bought before.
Lucia: 什么没到
Lucia: What hasn't arrived?
Lucia:笔吗
Lucia: The pens?
Jake:笔
Jake: The pens.
Katrina:  彩笔刚到
Katrina: The colored pens just arrived.
Jake: 彩笔
Jake: The colored pens.
Katrina: 刚到刚到菜鸟驿站
Katrina: Just arrived at the Cainiao station.
Katrina:  刚到菜鸟驿站
Jake: 哦那就还能领是吧
Jake: Oh, so we can still pick them up?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 今天还能
Jake: We can get them today?
Jake: 今天就能拿到了
Jake: We can get them today.
Jake: 催他们一下
Jake: Push them to hurry up.
Lucia: 雨轩有那种普通的写字的笔
Lucia: Yuxuan has that kind of normal writing pen.
Lucia: 但是我感觉往完了纸上可能有点
Lucia: But I feel like it might be a bit...
Lucia: 有点细做标记的话所以
Lucia: A bit fine for making marks on the paper, so...
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 那就去取快递
Jake: Then let's go get the package.
Tasha: 他虽然能上7个人
Tasha: Even though it can fit 7 people,
Tasha: 但是的卡牌里面的那个概率还是那个
Tasha: The probability in the card set is still that...
Tasha: 那个等级概率啊
Tasha: That level of probability, yeah.
Jake: 走把二楼给收拾收拾给你们跳舞用
Jake: Let's go clean up the second floor so you can dance there.
Shure:  二楼有什么
Shure: What's on the second floor?
Jake: 二楼有饺子
Jake: There are dumplings on the second floor.
Shure:  中午吃的饭还没熟呢
Shure: The lunch isn't even ready yet.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 找点事做
Jake: Let's find something to do.
Shure:  从何下手
Shure: Where do we start?
Shure: 这饼怎么都啃一半一半的
Shure: Why are all these buns half-eaten?
Jake:是俺硬撕的
Jake: I tore them apart.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:先放这 一会
Jake: Let's leave it here for now.
Jake:看心情在吃
Jake: Eat it later if we feel like it.
Jake:嗯 哎哟 我草
Jake: Hmm, oh my, darn.
Jake:有水
Jake: There's water.
Jake:不知道有点瞎
Jake: Didn't see it, a bit blind.
Shure: 是 说明这个眼镜的
Shure: Yeah, it means these glasses...
Jake:带来了一些基变
Jake: ...have caused some issues.
Shure: 透光率不好
Shure: The light transmission isn't good.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:看来得开灯
Jake: Looks like we need to turn on the lights.
俢硕: 当然有可能是佩戴者的问题
Shure: Or maybe it's the wearer's fault.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 但是暂且不考
Jake: But for now, let's not consider...
Jake: 虑这个事情
Jake: ...that possibility.
俢硕：默认佩戴者都是正常人类是吧
Shure: Assume the wearer is a normal human, right?
Jake: 哎 哎
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 我下去催人干活
Jake: I'm going downstairs to hurry people up.
Jake: 把没干没活的人叫上
Jake: Get those who aren't working to start.
Jake: 没亮又化了
Jake: It's not bright and it's melted again.
Lucia: sorry 我 把它成功重塑了一个非常短的视频
Lucia: Sorry, I successfully reshaped it into a very short video.
Jake: 好好那你再开一下
Jake: Alright, try opening it again.
Jake: 再来一个再来一个
Jake: Another one, another one.
Jake: 有快递拆吗
Jake: Any packages to open?
Jake: 没有那下午干什么
Jake: No? Then what are we doing this afternoon?
Lucia: 什么都可以
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Jake: 什么都可以
Jake: Anything is fine.
Jake: 有快递拆吗
Jake: Any packages to open?
Jake: 那下午干什么
Jake: Then what are we doing this afternoon?
Jake: 打金铲铲
Jake: Play Golden Shovel?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你应该有很多花要压
Jake: You probably have a lot of flowers to press.
Jake: 然后还需要有人帮你压花
Jake: And you still need someone to help you press them.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 我正在学着压花
Lucia: I'm learning how to press flowers.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 二楼要不有空收拾收拾
Jake: Maybe we should tidy up the second floor.
Nicous: 走吧
Nicous: Let's go.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:小狗在哪
Alice: Where's the puppy?
Jake: 狗在
Jake: The dog is...
Jake: 你活狗还是死狗
Jake: You mean alive or dead?
Tasha: 哈哈我天哪
Tasha: Haha, oh my gosh.
Jake: 活活哈哈哈活狗
Jake: Alive, haha, alive dog.
Katrina:  咖啡店那个吗
Katrina: The one at the cafe?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 活狗可以看一看
Jake: We can check out the live dog.
Jake: 咖啡店我我没去过
Jake: I haven't been to the cafe.
Jake: 据说200米很近
Jake: They say it's only 200 meters away.
Lucia: 我们可以先用自己的理念构思一只狗
Lucia: We can first imagine our own version of a dog.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 然后看画的狗和真正的狗长不长
Jake: Then see if the drawn dog looks like the real one.
Jake: 像不像
Jake: If it looks alike.
Lucia: 白马黑马
Lucia: White horse, black horse.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 走我们把二楼收拾收拾
Jake: Let's go tidy up the second floor.
Jake: 没没事的兄弟姐妹们
Jake: No worries, everyone.
Jake: 这地方能变成KTV吗
Jake: Can this place be turned into a KTV?
Shure:  可以
Shure: It can.
Shure:  可以变
Shure: It can be transformed.
Jake:怎 没办法要
Jake: How, we need...
Shure:  需要来一个麦克
Shure: We need a microphone.
Jake:那没有
Jake: We don't have that.
Jake: 确实要一个麦
Jake: We definitely need a mic.
Jake: 这麦插哪
Jake: Where to plug it in?
Jake: 插电脑上
Jake: Into the computer.
Shure:  对可以插在电脑上
Shure: Yes, it can be plugged into the computer.
Jake: 我们把这玩意剪成综艺会被骂死应该
Jake: If we edit this into a variety show, we'll probably get scolded to death.
俢硕: 为什么
Shure: Why?
Jake:就是浪费的东西
Jake: Just because it's a waste.
Jake: 现在一般综艺上面是不是都要
Jake: 就是都会特地标一个什么没浪费的
Shure:  对没有浪费
Shure:  给剧组人员全吃了
Jake:对对
Shure:  那我们这这么给剧组人员吃是吗
Nicous: 我们做的这些东西都是给 哎哟
Shure:  喂给流浪猫了
Nicous: 喂给流浪的小狗吃
Jake: 哦真的
Jake: 走我们喂狗去
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure:  他比咱吃的好
Shure:  说实话哈哈
Shure:  那只狗比我命应该金贵
Jake: 但是你可以玩了
Jake: 我先把这丢了吧
Jake: 然后你们再把这收拾
Jake:走
Jake:擦擦擦擦擦
Jake: 他你你这是得实时的监控他吗
Jake: Do you have to monitor him in real-time?
Nicous: 没有 你也不用太收拾
Nicous: No, you don't have to clean up too much.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 你的快递是拆完了
Jake: Did you finish unpacking your package?
Alice:还没到
Alice: It hasn't arrived yet.
Jake: 还没到
Jake: Not yet.
Jake: 然后我们一会把这桌子给搬空
Jake: Let's clear off this table in a bit.
Jake: 搬到墙角墙边
Jake: Move it to the corner or the wall.
Shure: 是要对这个桌子进行一下清理吗
Shure: Are we going to clean this table?
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 还有什么垃圾要扔吗
Jake: Any other trash to throw away?
Jake: 然后扔一下去
Jake: Then just toss it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 对进行一些适当清理
Jake: Yeah, let's do some proper cleaning.
Jake: 谢彬竹急了
Jake: Xie Bin is in a hurry.
Jake: 听说你把心如干蒙了
Jake: I heard you messed with Xinru.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 你你现在是第几
Jake: What place are you in now?
Tasha: 我现在是这个名字
Tasha: I go by this name now.
Tasha: 但是其实我只是一直在打连败的
Tasha: But actually, I've just been on a losing streak.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 心如现在还是短暂的第一名是吧
Jake: So Xinru is still temporarily in first place, right?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 但是你还是把他打蒙了
Jake: But you still managed to confuse him.
Jake: 他也想连败的
Jake: He also wants to be on a losing streak.
Tasha: 他也想连败的
Tasha: He also wants to be on a losing streak.
Lucia: 他浅浅的破防了
Lucia: He's slightly frustrated.
Tasha: 他想要连败
Tasha: He wants to be on a losing streak.
Tasha: 我也想要连败
Tasha: I also want to be on a losing streak.
Tasha: 但他连败不过我
Tasha: But he can't lose more than me.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 笑笑死我了
Tasha: This is making me laugh so hard.
Jake: 笑死了
Jake: It's hilarious.
Jake: 这个很难解释
Jake: This is hard to explain.
Jake: 不知道怎么怎么解释
Jake: I don't even know how to explain it.
Katrina:  看下小红书教程吧
Katrina: Let's check the tutorial on Little Red Book.
Katrina:  我也是瞎做
Katrina: I'm just winging it too.
Lucia: 看了但是感觉就这种厚的花
Lucia: I did, but it feels like these thick flowers...
Lucia: 就是很容易会缩
Lucia: They tend to shrink easily.
Lucia: 我在想你有什么办法让它不缩
Lucia: I'm wondering if you have any way to prevent that.
Katrina:  那你就可以压这种小花这样一放
Katrina: Then you can press these small flowers like this.
Lucia: 对对那种小花好压一下
Lucia: Yeah, those small ones are easier to press.
Lucia: 但我这个小的感觉它现在开的很旺盛
Lucia: But these small ones are blooming so well right now.
Lucia: 我有点舍不得把它剪下来
Lucia: I feel bad about cutting them.
Lucia: 残忍的咔咔
Lucia: It's so cruel.
Jake:剪一半
Jake: Just cut half.
Jake: 可以吗
Jake: Is that okay?
Lucia: 还可以这样
Lucia: Can we do that?
Lucia: 那剩下可以是可以啊
Lucia: Yeah, we can, but...
Lucia: 但那剩下的一半就会很孤单
Lucia: The remaining half will be lonely.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  但我这卖不出去啊
Katrina: But I can't sell this.
Lucia: 没事我们又不用真货币
Lucia: It's okay, we're not using real money.
Lucia: 而且
Lucia: Besides...
Lucia: 你接下来这个肯定会做的非常成功的
Lucia: Your next one will definitely be a success.
Lucia: 第一次那个只是试验品
Lucia: The first one was just a trial.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 哎对齐一下
Jake: Hey, align it properly.
Katrina:  你买那个钟
Katrina: Buy that clock.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 那个钟就是每一层放一个
Jake: That clock, we put one on each level.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 就是每一帧都知道时间对不对
Jake: So, every frame has a timestamp, right?
Jake: 就是可以测试用
Jake: It's for testing purposes.
Jake: 其实每一帧都是有时间
Jake: Actually, every frame has a timestamp.
Jake: 就是对一下
Jake: Just to check.
Lucia: 理论上说拍电影是应该这样的
Lucia: In theory, that's how filming a movie should be.
Lucia: 不过我鉴于我们这个不是电影所以
Lucia: But considering this isn't a movie...
Jake: 哎你看过的对吧
Jake: Hey, you've seen it, right?
Tasha: 看过了嗯
Tasha: Yes, I've seen it.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我觉得就他吧
Lucia: I think it's him.
Tasha: 我打不过你
Tasha: I can't beat you.
Nicous: 你别又打不过我
Nicous: Don't lose again.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Nicous: 你刚刚才赢的
Nicous: You just won.
Tasha: 你赢不是好吗
Tasha: Isn't it good that you won?
Tasha: 你看我打不过你
Tasha: See, I can't beat you.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How about it?
Jake: 你们两个人只能交锋一次是吗
Jake: Can you guys only clash once?
Nicous: 这么说我破防
Nicous: Are you saying I broke my defense?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 骂游戏了
Jake: Cursing the game.
Lucia: 我说他浅浅的破防哈哈哈
Lucia: I said he barely broke his defense, haha.
Nicous: 她套我话 就是你给我说撸把撸把
Nicous: She tricked me, saying "Let's play LoL."
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Nicous: 撸把没关系 可以玩
Nicous: It's okay, we can play.
Tasha: 可以玩
Tasha: We can play.
Nicous: 玩成这样了
Nicous: Playing like this.
Tasha: 哈哈你看你还在第一名呢
Tasha: Haha, look, you're still in first place.
Tasha: 这不是一个好兆头吗
Tasha: Isn't that a good sign?
Nicous: 哇靠 你刚拆我背景 当狗插
Nicous: Wow, you just ruined my background, like a dog.
Tasha: 哎我刚刚也被人破防了一次
Tasha: Hey, I just got my defense broken too.
Tasha: 好吧我到现在才六几名
Tasha: Well, I'm still only in the 60s.
Nicous: 还好 是哪个人
Nicous: It's okay, who was it?
Nicous: 我给他
Nicous: I'll get them.
Tasha: 叫蛰伏他已经走了
Tasha: It was Hibernation, but he's already gone.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Lucia: 浅浅的刮抹一下
Lucia: Just a light touch.
Katrina:  我这一层是厚的
Katrina:  之前压的花瓣
Katrina: The petals I pressed before.
Jake: 我也要喝
Jake: I want a drink too.
Tasha: 你几级啊 你六级
Tasha: What level are you? You're level six.
Tasha: 你知道我要上10级了吗马上
Tasha: You know I'm about to reach level 10 soon.
Jake: 上面桌子搬完了吗
Jake: Have you finished moving the tables upstairs?
Shure:  擦完了
Shure: Finished wiping them.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 什么
Jake: What?
Shure: 我的放在微波炉前
Shure: I put mine in front of the microwave.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  还有一个
Shure: There's another one.
Jake: flower
Jake: 这么转正好
Jake: Turning it like this is just right.
Jake:flower这边
Jake: flower over here.
Jake: 牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Shure:  然后我们现在要用二层干嘛
Shure: So what are we doing with the second layer now?
Jake:回头你们要跳舞
Jake: Later you guys need to dance.
俢硕: 啊
Jake:我操
俢硕: 我差点忘了
Shure:  我们还有
Jake: 你们还有重要任务
俢硕：人家不爆杀你嘛
Shure:  随便杀他装备都没上呢
Shure:  略施小计就把你玩的团团转谢彬竹
俢硕: 我我是建立这个经济体系的人嘛
Shure:  你忘记了吗
Shure:  我的唯一任务就是把货币做出来
Katrina:  货币已经买了
Shure:  OK解决解决
Shure:  伟大无需多言
Jake: 落地了是吧
Shure:  对
Jake:伟大的构想
Shure:  是的
Shure:  你知道我国第一个货币叫做什么吗
Shure:  让我
Shure: Let me
Jake: 修币
Jake: Shure coin
Shure:  那出出现在哪个哪个朝代
Shure: So, in which dynasty did it appear?
Jake: 到 到  多 dog币
Jake: To, to, more dog coin
Jake:dog
Jake: dog
Jake:狗狗币
Jake: Dogecoin
Shure:  宋代的骄子
Shure: The pride of the Song dynasty
Shure:  是我国第一个出现的纸币
Shure: It was the first paper currency in our country
Jake: 哪真的呀这是
Jake: Really, is that true?
Shure:  需要帮忙吗
Shure: Need any help?
Katrina:  还有一个板你想做也可以做
Katrina: There's another board you can work on if you want
Tasha: 我觉得利安卓在这个版本最厉害
Tasha: I think Lissandra is the strongest in this version
Tasha: 5费卡里面
Tasha: Among the 5-cost cards
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 那刀妹和猴子的话就猴子厉害点吧
Tasha: Between Irelia and Wukong, Wukong is a bit stronger
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn
Tasha: 我靠你到底要什么你说嘛
Tasha: Seriously, what do you want?
Tasha: 你可以拿第二的
Tasha: You can take the second place
Tasha: 我可以把第二的位置让给你牌给你
Tasha: I can give you the second place and the cards
Jake: 谢彬竹还能拿个第二啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu can still take the second place?
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: That's impressive
Shure:  说实话
Shure: Honestly
Shure:  其实其他6个应该都是人机
Shure: Actually, the other 6 are probably bots
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 所以输不过他们
Tasha: So we can't beat them
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Jake: 哦人机很牛逼
Jake: Oh, bots are quite strong
Shure:  不是所以他一个人类都没有几百
Shure: No, so he didn't beat a single human
Shure:  他就是人类中的倒数第一
Shure: He is the worst among humans
Shure:  我们这左侧的这个RGB是干嘛的
Shure: What's this RGB on our left for?
Jake: 你说这个灯吗
Jake: You mean this light?
Jake: 它就是光
Jake: It's just light
Jake: 然后分光了
Jake: Then it disperses
Jake: 它就是白光
Jake: It's white light
Jake: 然后它往这边它就它就分了
Jake: Then it disperses in that direction
Jake: 它就是分了
Jake: It just disperses
Tasha: 我谁都打不过
Tasha: I can't beat anyone
Tasha: 不你为什么不往第二名
Tasha: No, why don't you aim for second place?
Tasha: 哈哈干嘛呀
Tasha: Haha, what's up?
Tasha: 哎三星乌迪尔了
Tasha: Hey, a three-star Udyr
Tasha: 就这样我等等呀
Tasha: Just like that, I'll wait
Shure:  没有那个是镜像过来的
Shure: No, that's mirrored.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure:  你不给他装这个了吗
Shure: Aren't you going to install this for him?
Tasha: 哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 不是我装的
Tasha: I didn't install it.
Tasha: 这是神器变的
Tasha: It's a magic tool.
Shure:  bomb has been planted是吧
Shure: "bomb has been planted", right?
Jake: 我靠这东西还能搞闹钟
Jake: Oh my, this thing can be used as an alarm clock.
Katrina:  你做那小狗呗
Katrina: You make that little dog.
Tasha: 我把一只两星的卖了
Tasha: I sold a two-star one.
Tasha: 在干嘛哈哈哈
Tasha: What are you doing, haha.
Tasha: 他怎么上不上去装备了
Tasha: Why can't he equip it?
Nicous:  靠你上你给的是那个哎
Nicous: Come on, you gave him that thing.